وفادت مراسله الجزيره بخبر استشهاد سته
فلسطينيين قبل قليل بقصف من مسيره
اسرائيليه على موقع عند مدخل جنين الجنوبي
شمال الضفه الغربيه واضافت المراسله ان
مقاومين تمكنوا من اعطاب اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه بعبوات ناسفه شديده الانفجار
قبل ان يستهدفهم القصف
الجوي شفي
قصف صور مشاهدينا
وصلتنا قبل قليل
لوقع القصف الذي استشهد به سته شبان
فلسطينيين في قصف
مسيره
اسرائيليه لمدخل جنين الجنوبي في شمال
الضفه الغربيه هون يا شباب مشان الله طول
روس طله يا شباب مشان النبي يا
عمي يرم
فيش راس فيش
راس شرفي كصف هون يا شباب مش الله طول فيش
روؤس فيش شيش طل يا شباب بسرعه مشان النبي
يا
عمي الله
يرحمك فيش راس فيش
راس
شرافي كصف هون يا شباب مشان الله طل فيش
رؤس في شي طل يا شباب بسرعه مشان النبي يا
عمي فيش راس فيش
راس بالراس